do you see the same issues that you
discussed now at Harvard uh at MIT we're
here in Boston so I have to talk about
the the great universities here in
Boston you've written about MIT I'm uh
the university I love I'm a research
scientist there
um do you see the same kind of issues
there yes I do do you remember can you
explain the case of Dorian Abbott
lecture that was canceled at MIT yeah
well you know it's this is this is not
the only it's not the only incident
um there have been incidents all around
the country
um of academics professors who have
views that don't comport with the uh as
the great Lily at home and another
friend of my late wife
said they they they
she said she refused to cut her garments
in order to fit the Fashions of the day
um Dorian Abbott didn't cut his suit
um to fit the Fashions of the day in his
intellectual suit
and so he was um this has happened at
Princeton this has happened at Harvard
this has happened at MIT
the great universities in the country
um have decided that the Clash of ideas
is not such a good idea because some
people's feelings will be heard
well this is there was quite a revolt
against it
um fire
sounded the alarm
and then in the end the universities
were I believe Abbott was invited to
come back I think he turned them down
uh he's I he he shouldn't have turned
him down but he did
um and um when when the light is cast
upon these situations the universities
back down because they're so embarrassed
yeah
um and the newspapers because newspapers
depend on the First Amendment in order
to exist newspapers tend to give pretty
good publicity to these cases of
censorship so they grow the universities
yes so they they really emphasize they
catalyze the embarrassment yes so is
that one of the ways is that the best
way to fight all of this yes sunshine is
the best disinfectant